Okay. Have we talked about a co-taught SUSE boss before? I don't remember.
I don't think we have, we have explained them to the audience.
So if they watch anime, you are chatting me. Right. You know what,
if you don't know what I could,
Tatsu is basically like a heated coffee table where it's like a,
it's like a little coffee table where that has blankets around it and you put
your legs in it and you put them under and it's all nice and cozy and warm.
And it is amazing.
I don't know about amazing. I think it's amazing.
There's a few logistical issues that crop up with us such as well.
How many legs can fit under that.
Once a month? How big the table is now? Big. Depends on.
All of a sudden it's normally not that big it's normally you can comfortably
probably fit two people's legs.
I mean, are you, are you, are you wearing this to Micah? Totsy which is tiny.
No, no, no. Like a normal potassium. Cause like I want to put,
I want to stretch my legs fully out of that thing. Yeah.
You can only really fit like two before you start. Like, you know,
you start touching people's legs. I don't want to touch Jerry's legs.
Discuss all my homies.
I don't want to play.
Footsie with Joey under the table.
Oh, I'm so stop. I want to twiddle toes. I call Luna.
What if you don't know them? Super. Are you pretty dude at the welfare?
If you, if you're sharing it to curtains,
I'm not sharing your photos with the street.
Yeah. Why not? That should be, that should be in a restaurant. It's nice.
But then also I find that it's like, I think you could turn it up and down,
but it's like, it's either like I would rather the room be hot,
then my legs be hot. Does that make sense? No.
Oh, okay. I've I've I've I literally had this problem recently, which is like,
why I, I re I, I get reminded why I really don't like winter. Right?
So unlike the, unlike these boys, I hate the cold and I hate winter.
I love the cleanse. Like the reason I hate it is because you know,
you're in a cold room and you want to get comfortable.
So what'd you do you put on the heater,
but I hate the feeling of a stuffy room or like the deck,
like this room is getting a bit from a stuffy country though.
Have you considered wearing another item.
Of clothing?
Because there's a problem because if you wear like a jumper or something and the
rooms code, then your hands are cold. And like, I'm just trying to work.
Not that I can get.
That coat, the blood circulate to your fingers and off,
or my feet. Like before we turned on the seats of my fever, ice cold,
man, I am not joking
[inaudible] with your body. Like what the? I just, I,
my body was just not built for the cold and there's nothing more uncomfortable
for me then just the opposite then just a stuffy room. Cause like,
sometimes I'm like, maybe I'm getting ill.
And then I realized I go outside and it's because the room's so stuffy that I
haven't realized how uncomfortable I'm feeling. That's why,
that's why I very rarely turn on the heater unless it's like a seriously cold.
Because for me it's like, if I'm cold,
I'll just wear another layer of clothing and then Hey, the room isn't stuffy.
I'm old. But also it's really easy to make a room stuff.
You just open a window for like one minute after you've heated the room up.
It won't be.
Yeah. But then, but then after you opened the window, then it gets cold again.
And then the cycle continues on in one in it. There, there is,
there is like never,
there is never like a perfect temperature that I'm like happy with when it's
winter. Because if, if I need to like artificially warm it up,
then either it's going to be too stuffy or I'm going to be too cold.
There is no between.
So nice about being in a warm room, knowing it's freezing out.
Magical about it. It's like going to bed in a thunderstorm, right? Like there's,
there's something comforting about it. Yeah. I dunno if you
[inaudible]
, I just gave you like a thousand yard stare. Like you were like, I know what you mean. Yeah.
It's like the it's just like white noise outside.
It's there's something comforting about like outside is right now, but I'm safe.
Drywall. Some of the best sleeps I've had, I've been like camping on the floor,
but because it's so freezing outside and you need a little like warm cocoon.
Oh nice. Yeah. I agree. I agree. I agree. I just like,
I just like being comfortable existing, I guess.
Like I don't want to do anything to make my existence more comfortable.
I just like being in a room and being like, okay, I can do whatever I want.
I think you just spoke on behalf of all humanity. I just want to,
I just want a comfortable exams. I just want to be,
he just wants to wear a turtle neck in his room and, and be a happy boy.
Honestly. What's wrong with that? I don't want to put on a heater. Okay.
To be honest, the only reason why I, okay.
Two reasons why I don't wear turtlenecks. Hey, you're looking.
I looked like a Dick and B. I might leave Handjobs here though.
You can make a wound. I can't make it work.
I looked like I looked like a weirdo with a turtleneck,
but be like my neck for some reason. I don't know what it is.
It exerts so much heat. That's like legit.
Like that's the reason why like I, like,
I can't wear a scarf either because when I wear a scarf, my Nick gets so.
Swayed. I love wearing scarf.
I love, I love wearing scarves too,
but only if it's like really like I'm talking like minus 10 minus 20 degrees.
Literally the,
the reason I thought I'd wait until the next had nothing to do with like me
thinking toe. Next looks looks nice.
I just remember the first time I put on a turtleneck, I'm like, Oh,
this is like permanently wearing a scarf that I'd never have to take off.
Perfect. For me. I love the feeling of waste.
It doesn't matter like how cold it is for me. I don't know why I get so sweaty.
Who needs renewable energy. When we can just use Joey's phone.
All hovered around my neck, like this and just warm your hands up on my neck.
Like, I don't know why. I don't know what it is.
Like my neck is so hot and which sucks because people have always told me,
Oh yeah, you look really good in the scarf. And I'm like, yeah,
I'll look when wearing scuffs. Don't like the feeling of it,
but I can only wear for me. You say that you're fine,
but you're not really fine. Exactly. It's like, it's like,
I like wearing a scarf and I think I look good in a scarf,
but the point is I can't wear a scarf for more than two minutes.
Cause then I'm just.
Like, this. It's so hot.
Overheating overload. I.
Kind of on of, but.
Yeah. Going back to why I like the tattoos is that co-taught SUSE is like,
I can feel warmer cutout suit and not feel stuffy. So it's like one of,
one of the few spaces where I'm just like, if I'm getting hot,
I can just roll on the Tatsu.
But that's the problem I have with co-taught is this exact same problem I have
with beds in winter? It's that the moment I enter the cold tattoo,
the GS Jack up like 10 GS and I can't leave it. I felt.
Also, I don't really like sitting on the floor, like sitting on the floor.
Isn't that comfortable for me. Right.
And cause that's what you normally have to sit on the floor. Cause some like,
I need some like back support man, but those chairs. Yeah.
There's a pretty good bit like most of the time. Yeah.
They've already have those two days. Just kind of like you just sit,
put your light and you just put your hands back.
If you want to lean back a little bit, let me, you can lean back on the couch.
I mean, if there's a couch that people don't have that. Right. But whatever.
I mean I'm being niche. Usually just bring your own folder.
I'm like that guy with the camping chair, like flips it out with that hand.
I'm like, I'm ready for the coach. I'm ready to be comfortable. Yeah.
Honestly like cutoff season. I remember,
I remember the first time I tried out a guitar.
So you were here in Japan and it was like instant life-changing moment.
Wait, what do you mean? It's the warm table? What are you doing? Come on,
come on.
You have some of those moments where you just like,
how did I go my entire life without this? It is pretty wild.